[Musique]
l'acca de filière aéronautique espace
automobiles et ferroviaires transport
guidé chaque filière contribuer dans son
spectre aux réflexions et aux
enseignements sur la mobilité verte
il ya une spécialisation
eco mobilité en 5e année il ya d'abord à
cause des cours généraux de
développement durable donc sur le
réchauffement climatique sur
l'écomobilité l'éco-conception ça ce
sont des cours qui sont donnés en
deuxième et troisième années pour tous
les étudiants
ensuite par par filière on va travailler
sur les moteurs électriques sur
l'hydrogène sur les moteurs à gaz
on va travailler sur les allègements
donc sur les matériaux alors sur un
double aspect comment j'allège et
comment j'utilise des des matériaux
naturels
[Musique]
il ya des gens qui voient ça de manière
assez éloignée et il ya une frange qui
est mon avis du plu qui est tout à fait
croissante d'étudiants qui ont repéré ça
comme étant un enjeu essentiel de la
société donc il ya de plus en plus
d'étudiants qui ont des projets soient
de création d'entreprise qu'on
accompagne soit qui militent source à
des associations soit au sein soit
auprès de nous pour pro l'enseignement
pour développer ces aspects là et qu'ils
en font j'irais là le le le squelette ou
le hall orientations majeures de leur
future carrière